it's not often that we get to have a
terrorist on this show
but uh we're living in strange times and
so we have managed to secure one of the
most terrifying
intimidating dangerous terrorists that
we have seen in the west in a very long
time i'm not talking about a member of
al qaeda
not talking about a member of boko haram
no someone far
far more intimidating
a member of the canadian freedom convoy
yes that would be nicholas mann
a 27 year old canadian
born and raised in ontario where was
this man radicalized he's been a blue
collar worker for 11 years now trackman
operator for five years in ontario then
six years in water and sewer in alberta
this man
he he got radicalized somewhere he
joined the uh freedom convoy protest in
ottawa on january 28th as it drove by
his hometown
and now he is being prosecuted nicholas
thank you for coming on the show
thanks for having me it's uh that was
quite the intro i appreciate it
you seem very scary and dangerous a true
threat to western civilization
uh can you tell us a little bit
about how you found yourself now
being prosecuted for apparently
committing a crime
well you know when we heard that uh
there were millions of
like-minded canadians who uh many of
which were gonna drive four thousand
kilometers to uh to contest these
mandates these passports that we all
think are morally wrong
we there wasn't any place we were gonna
be but in ottawa standing with the rest
of them and uh you know unfortunately it
deteriorated a little bit but uh but
that's how we came to be there
it was great for the 10 days we were
there again great people it was a shame
that uh the abuse of the law there the
what would you call it the
misapplication of law that led us to be
charged
so just trying to get georgia tell me a
little bit about that law because
obviously we're joking you know you
don't exactly seem like uh you know al
zawahiri or anything like that so
you you and lots of other canadians
protested these onerous vaccine mandates
the the government's insistence that
people who were not at any particularly
great risk of dying of the coronavirus
take these experimental vaccines or else
they lose their livelihoods they lose
their reputations they lose everything
and there was a big protest
to this effect the government invoked
the emergencies act
and then and then shut the whole thing
down can you tell us a little bit about
that
absolutely i mean you can see the wild
misapplication of the law right from the
get-go right they started violating the
charter rights and freedoms which there
are situations where that can be done
and there it has to be demonstrable
brian peckford the last living signatory
of the charter lays it out much more
eloquently than i could but there are
ways you can do what he did
he definitely didn't follow any of that
procedure um moving on from there they
started misapplying the criminal code
which is how they got me uh
just with mischief and obstruction
charges and then on top of that they
misapplied the emergency act
unprecedented you can call it the war
times act which is old man
enacted but justin chose to for the
first time employ the emergency act to
break up
peaceful protesters in ottawa give him
powers to freeze bank accounts to you
know use mischief as a way to charge and
prosecute the people that were there now
this whole thing is is pretty jarring
from my view as an american because i
remember
2020
for what eight months was it you had blm
and antifa
burning down city after city after city
in our own country and we were told that
those were mostly peaceful protesters
then you had a handful of eccentrics go
into the capital rotunda on january 6th
wearing horn hats sort of dancing around
and taking pictures and we were told
that they were the greatest terrorist
threat in in the history of our country
insurrectionists who almost took down
the constitution and it just seemed so
insane i mean one group killed dozens of
people burned federal buildings torched
city after city the other group cracked
a coors light in the capital and and yet
we were told that the latter was far
more dangerous than the former uh
are the leftist groups that that protest
that riot even in canada are they are
they prosecuted are they are they
treated with the same severity that you
guys have been or is this like in
america a totally asymmetrical response
it seems to be asymmetrical as you say
you know
our prime minister took a knee with them
he ran away from us
um it wasn't uh it wasn't while our
protest was going on that there were
actual
violent attacks on uh on pipelines out
west that wasn't reported for days just
like our own prime minister said when
you spend 600 million dollars
it greases the wheels for the stellar
headlines that he gets i'm paraphrasing
a bit i imagine it works the same with
you guys where the left-wing media is
completely bought and paid for and they
toe the party line
do you think that the trucker convoy do
you think it accomplished anything or do
you think trudeau
won and and got everything he wanted and
and now he's going to punish his
opponents
i i can't i can't believe that he won
the war he certainly won the battle but
uh
you know we we didn't know that we had
so many supporters we thought we were
the friends just like he did right you
know but uh we we know our strength now
we know what can be accomplished and if
you look at all over the all over this
country you got alberta completely
lifting mandates you got saskatchewan
manitoba even some of the east coast
ontario still him and han a little bit
but there have been victories and they
could say had nothing to do with us all
they want but you know we all know the
timeline we all know what they were
saying before we know we accomplished
something
i think you're probably right i mean if
you look at that timeline clearly the
trucker convoy sent a message and and
local politicians at least are listening
but what about you guys i mean you're
still going to have to pay the price for
going up against trudeau so what what
are you looking at in terms of
actual punishment from the government
well i see you know i'm not terribly
experienced with the judicial system
i've never been arrested before in my
life so there's some hope there that
they you know they don't slam the book i
mean of course again i'm worried enough
that they might
move to make an example of the few that
they did get but my charges of mischief
and mischief obstruction of property uh
carry away to two years each max
wow two yeah good grief that's for
did you
did you commit crimes i mean is there
did you throw a molotov cocktail at the
building did you assault people what
what are they even charging you with
uh well what we did was uh you know with
the donations from our family and the
great people that we met there we
brought fuel in jerry cans we went to
the we went to the gas stations we
filled them up we brought them to the
truckers that were close to empty we put
them in there in their trucks and then
we moved on all day we had no problem
you know police officers waving to us
smiling telling us lift with your biceps
until all of a sudden they were grabbing
the whole bus
and it just turned out to be me but
thrown in the car and charged
how did you choose which internet
service provider to use the sad thing is
most of us have very little choice
because isps operate like monopolies in
the regions they serve that's why you
got to check out expressvpn
expressvpn is a fabulous way to protect
your data from isps who want to look at
all of your data i protect all of my
devices with expressvpn it's a simple
app for your computer or smartphone it
encrypts all your network data and
tunnels it through a secure vpn server
so that your isp cannot see any of your
activity just think about how much of
your life is on the internet think about
all those websites you go to
you know on the incognito window that's
not so incognito you know websites that
could get you in a lot of trouble if
people found out about it talk about
dailywire.com and other right-wing
websites they can get you into a lot of
trouble all right so use expressvpn
great way to hide your activity online
from your isp download the app push the
button you're ready to go protect
yourself with the vpn that i trust to
keep me safe online go to expressvpn.com
michael yt do it do not browse for even
one more second without protecting
yourself expressvpn.com michael yt for
three extra months for free
so this is this is not a case because
what what we were hearing here in the
united states is that look it just seems
like the truckers are honking because
they don't want to take the fouchy algae
and this experimental drug and and you
know give in to this bizarre global
elite that's misled us for two years no
it's not about that they're nazis they
have nazi flags they're white
supremacists they're violent they're
attacking people and buildings and so
you've got to put it down as the most
violent dangerous group of people we've
seen in a very long time
what you're describing doesn't sound
very violent at all
it certainly wasn't you know don't get
me wrong there were definitely a couple
of bad actors in the
swastika flying the confederate flag who
knows if they were plants but they
certainly got great pictures of them
right off the hop you know they there
were things that were uncorroborated
like the uh they said they were stealing
food from the homeless the homeless
people have never been better fed better
clothed you know i had i had a couple
hanging out with my truck just to get
warm then they'd move on it was a great
experience um the streets were cleaner
uh the snow was shoveled you know they
said desecrating memorials but all i saw
were veterans standing proud beside a
memorial you know it just uh it seemed
wild misreporting from the get-go
there's a couple independent news
sources that uh that showed up for
canada and then of course you guys
showed up and we were great to have you
know the fox news is the right-wing
media actually telling the story like it
was it was pretty great to see
well i i am glad that the real news
could get out because you're really
seeing it right now
in in russia and ukraine's war that's
going on which is that the propaganda
will fly around the world before anyone
can verify anything you mention that who
knows if maybe the swastika flag was a
plant we've seen that a number of times
in american rallies there was there was
one i forget exactly which rally it was
a guy had a big confederate flag out and
he was positioning himself right in
front of all the news cameras and you
saw he actually had a little wire going
into his ear
they weren't hiding it very well there
was a rally we had here in america
called justice for january 6th and when
you looked at the photos from the rally
you realized
90 of the people there were left-wing
journalists
nine percent of the people there were
feds there was there was this great
picture of obvious federal agents all
wearing the same kind of nondescript
clothes all standing in a circular
formation situational awareness you know
a total joke it's it's like they had
just gotten their hair cut at langley
and then walked out to the rally and
then i don't know there were probably
two guys from appalachia who hadn't
gotten the memo that this was all all a
big op
but but you you did have that sense
looking at the trucker convoy as you say
seems like these guys were relatively
peaceful they wanted a sort of common
sense thing
what is your take
beyond the activists out in the streets
on the political temperature of canada
itself is the tide turning in a more
conservative reasonable direction or is
prime minister pretty boy still enjoying
support
i think i think it's certainly turning
you know the fear-mongering can only go
on for so long the people are either the
left-wing activists or the people that
are just so terrified because they've
been conned into it you know they don't
they think their children are at risk
they don't really see the actual
information they've never done their own
cost risk analysis with information that
they've gone and
cleaned themselves and so i think it's
turning i think you can only keep people
scared for so long i know that's their
game but it seems like people are waking
up you know as you see less and less
people with mass
um you know it's uh it seems to be
turning i think i think we've started a
movement i don't think we're going away
and and i think we can continue this
ball rolling until until it's over do
you think the trucker convoy will turn
into a more formal political party i i
remember uh ten years or so ago that
there was the tea party movement in the
united states and they they never quite
became an official political party but
they exerted a huge amount of political
influence in 2010 2012 and that was just
after a sort of spontaneous rally is a
lot like the freedom convoy uh i think
uh i think we already have one in the
people's party of canada maxine bernie
has been has been uh you know uh an
arbiter of freedom since since he uh he
left the conservative party you know the
conservative party has done uh started
to speak out you know and uh fight for
canadian freedoms but it's it's
it's a little and it's it's a little
late you know we have we have
conservative premiers that are that are
uh
in bed with the uh with the what do you
call them the sticker companies you know
they they love they're making lots of
money
um where you know off the people's fear
and these restrictions you know making
money off people going out of business
when when they should have been standing
up for our rights all along so no i
think the people's party of canada will
see a lot more than the 5 10
that they had in the last federal
election well i think you're probably
right to knock the conservatives a
little there's a line from chesterton
who said the job of the progressive is
to make mistakes and the job of the
conservative is to make sure those
mistakes don't get fixed so every so
often you need a little injection of of
energy and a different way of thinking
about things so
okay i amend my introduction of you you
are not the the next coming of uh al
zarqawi you are not a terrorist you seem
like an ordinary guy works an ordinary
job just wants to stand up for freedom
in your country no criminal record when
is your court date
uh march 3rd march 3rd okay and uh
you have a good lawyer are you feeling
confident uh you know
how are your uh comrades feeling you
know the people who are out there with
you uh you know what what what are the
predictions
yeah you know there's definitely mix you
don't know if they're looking to make
examples of people you know the violence
started even after i was arrested the
violence started obviously on the side
of the police against these people
protesters so i don't know you know i
don't know if they will hit them harder
than they hit me
um yeah again we have high hopes because
most of us never been in trouble with
the law before you know there's no
reason unless it's you know vindictive
prosecution which
with our prime minister and our
left-leaning judges you know that very
well may be the case
but uh we we definitely have high hopes
um i've spoken to some other people that
uh you know they were released fairly
quickly and their charges seem to be
roughly similar so
unless they hit us with the four years
each you know we do have high hopes i i
look forward to letting you guys know uh
how it goes well i certainly hope so i i
hope we can have a follow-up because
you know we hear a lot of fear-mongering
from the left in america and in canada
and the west broadly fear-mongering over
authoritarianism overseas well
if they throw you in the can
for filling up the gas tanks of some
freedom protesters
then i think that the greater threat of
authoritarianism is is over here and uh
so we can hope for you we can shed a
little bit of light on this if you are
seriously prosecuted here i think it's
just a clear example of the suppression
of political dissent in canada and
america we've seen a lot of it in recent
years but hopefully you'll you'll be
able to make it out and we can
push the ball down the court in in
protection of our way of life and our
rights and our freedoms a little bit
further
no i i i couldn't agree more you know
that you said there's a fear of the
left-leaning judges they've given them a
lot of power a lot of control over
things that you know probably never
should have happened with the freezing
of the bank accounts putting pastures in
in solitary confinement just on the with
their thoughts of going out to one of
these protests is just insanity and i
hope
i hope with enough uh with enough
people looking on but you know at the
very least he'll be quelled himself if
not uh if not
voted out that's right it's very very
important that people not get distracted
by by what the media and the
establishment want us to focus on we
focus on the real threats right here at
home nicholas thank you so much best of
luck to you and we'll have to check back
in after march 3rd
thank you so much it's great to hear
from you
[Music]
[Music]
you